gira el segmento menos 90 grados
alrededor de el origen y nos dan este
segmento de aquí esto es el que tenemos
que rotar menos 90 grados así que voy a
activarme herramienta de rotación
y como me dicen que tengo que rotar
alrededor del origen voy a colocar este
punto justo en el origen al rededor de
este punto voy a rotar ahora cómo voy a
rotar menos 90 grados voy a moverme
conforme a las manecillas del reloj por
esta cantidad así que estas flechas que
aquí están abrazando al eje x tienen que
ahora abrazar al eje y pero por acá
abajo así que vamos a ver nuevo las
modelos nuevo y ahí quedan entonces esto
es una rotación por menos 90 grados
alrededor del origen
ahora tenemos que responder algunas
preguntas cuando el segmento de línea ha
explotado el resultado es un 1
segmento claro y luego nos dicen sabemos
que esto es cierto porque la imagen rota
da tiene
dos puntos extremos tiene estos dos
puntos extremos la imagen rota da es
de la misma longitud que el segmento de
línea original claro no modificamos la
longitud del segmento
y bien estamos en lo correcto